hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I am NOT Ryan
Ryan no he is Jerry Jerry today we're
gonna check out the second trailer for
The Man From UNCLE it's an acronym it's
a spy movie it looks great before we do
that I did want to talk about something
real fast that we just watched
oh yeah it's his documentary online and
I don't really watch them any
documentaries so I think the smartest
guy yeah and I feel a little bit more
intelligent each time this one was
called the most dangerous town
how would you describe it it's a short
form documentary about cybercrime and
it's sort of centers around this sort of
small town in Romania where a lot of
cyber crime happens right right there's
a lot of great points in there that are
actually found really interesting some
of the most prolific hackers who have
stolen billions of dollars are out there
you might see like crazy hacker
characters and movies like hacking into
the government and stuff and it always
seems like it's just a bit stilted and a
bit like you know glammed oh yeah I'm
totally fictionalized so then you find
out that they're like real people who
did it and I'm like looking at these
people and these are just like regular
dudes and it's pretty surprising there's
an annotation link to check it out and
it's also in the description box so go
ahead check this out because I'm saying
- maybe you should look into semantic
anti hack software yeah it was presented
by northern security and Norton security
and yeah what I'm gonna do is get Norton
because that seems like a trustworthy
advocate for Internet security
well I always had their antivirus offer
and that worked really well for me
yeah security from Norton Norton
security anyway let's watch this trailer
man From UNCLE starring Armie Hammer who
was the star of the greatest movie of
all time The Lone Ranger and heard Henry
Cavill the most charismatic spider-man
we've ever had
you told me this was gonna be a simple
extraction they were waiting for me what
was waiting for me was barely human the
toilet back of my car
grow a spine so low
Wow
this was the most dangerous time in our
history exactly I think it is we
recently discovered an international no
choice but to work together mess
teaming up with Russia doesn't summery
friendly really fight each other no mess
we both forget about the mark this is
not the rational way Victoria
Vinciguerra it will send an army to stop
us we must give them an appropriate
welcome these business or the mission if
we get to know each other a little bit
more intimately that means I like my
woman strong very special day
yeah so sorry I can't stay to finish
sending a signal you want to check it be
my guest
what are you doing down there why not to
finish things could get a little messy
absolutely head work from the defender a
terrible spy cowboy
you tell me you ran back oh and you have
a new code name code name
I like when when like charming romantic
comedy British actors get older because
then they start playing like classy
badasses yeah it's like Colin Firth is
doing the same thing right now
I think that's amusing yeah armie hammer
does a good [ __ ] Russian accent yeah
because he's got that already naturally
commanding American voice it like
translates into like a really bold type
of Russian accent you know it's cool
yeah well I see here's the things like
this kind of has that sort of like more
fun but still kind of classy look like
we're James Bond right now is being very
serious and interest back I don't like
anybody James Bond yeah this reminds me
of more of like a an older James Bond
movie I kind of like that sort of like
all 60s intrigue we're going all over
the place
yeah it's got the tone in the vibe and
if there's anyone who could provide that
I do see that Guy Ritchie's the kind of
director who could pull that off
Guy Ritchie like seems like a good
choice for this but I'm sort of worried
that it's just gonna turn out like okay
- pretty good because he's kind of got
the same career as Tim Burton right now
and he used to do these like really
ubiquitous original things and now he's
like adapting things that are pretty
good you know I mean for the most part
though Guy Ritchie is films eat normally
one thing that's in there is energy and
I feel like you know this film will
definitely need that type of energy he
knows how to have his characters banter
really well
all those elements that Guy Ritchie is
known to be good at seem to be at play
here in this film and that's what I like
about it reading in the middle my model
from the few moments we got a Henry
Cavill the lead actor who is not really
being portrayed as the lead is someone
show a lot of people mister he he looks
already a lot more charming than his
portrayal of Clark Kent which I don't
mind but because I mean that gets into a
problem with that kind of movie because
especially like a movie like Man of
Steel now is very much like okay the
main character has to be brooding all
the time yeah
whereas this kind of doesn't look like
it's so constrained by those things it's
like especially a big popcorn like
superhero fare it's like everyone's got
to be serious all the time and I don't
think this we'll get into that as much
another thing that I really do enjoy
about the trailer was you see Henry
Cavill and then army hammers the one
who's kind of got the super-strength and
it's cool me
henry cavill is like taking now more of
this he's not clearly not the Superman
of this movie you know it's something
that he will have to work on
establishing outside a Man of Steel was
his own separate career yeah so I'm
really rooting for you buddy well it's a
good time to get another movie going
yeah yeah like this has this a it's a
good time to get this kind of film going
- especially after Kingsman and I think
it would be good for army hammer to sort
of pop up and do some more supporting
stuff just to remind us that like oh
yeah this guy's good and he doesn't have
to carry a giant movie you know while
doing it it looks like he can share the
load share quotes Samwise Gamgee 'he's
mouth closed up huh
share the load with someone's mouth
[ __ ] party no no why I don't know you
said sure the loathing said mouth I
specifically alluded to the Lord of the
Rings trilogy hearing so deal with it
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to this channel on this
channel
these reasons the charity and dank ass
ups you should check it out and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine where if we get enough
followers money through product
placement to help us out with gettin
that moolah for things such as car keys
car alarms car alarms are great you know
you never know when you need one for
example you might be like getting mugged
or you might be getting taken advantage
of like in a sexual way but what if you
like it that's why you get an option if
whether or not you want to let the alarm
go off if you like it you're not being
taken advantage of and then when you're
coming and then you let the alarm go off
so that way it replicates the level of
orgasm for you through the engine not
the engine the automobile so it's like
some kind of weird automotive blumpkin
car alarms so